I'm Ray Britton and I'm the Scoutmaster with Group 42 in Oak Ridge, Tennessee.
This edition of Scoutmaster Podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
Keep up the good work part.
And now for you, Scoutmaster,
I'd love to get out camping. I'd love to get outside, go commune with nature,
As long as nature doesn't try to commune back with mosquitoes or bears or things like that.
Hey, everybody, make sure to tip your waiters and try the ramen noodles.
The ramen noodles are great.
This is Podcast number 315..
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster Podcast. This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look in this week's mailbag.
A couple of podcasts ago, my pal Walter under would join me
And we did a discussion about our impressions of the new,
the new, the new, the new, the new, the new, the new, the new, the new, the new, the new, the new, the new.
And we did a discussion about our impressions of the new Troup Leader guidebook, the first volume.
And I heard from the author this past week, Mark Ray, who said:
Hey, Clark, thanks for the kind words about volume one of the Troup Leader guidebook.
Volume two has been released to the printer,
So I'm guessing it will hit the scout shops this summer.
I'd love to chat with you when you're ready to do a podcast about it,
about it. I'm proud of volume one,
but I'm really proud of volume two,
which includes a lot of stuff we've never offered
adult volunteers before.
So I'm working with Mark on that
and in advance of volume two going out
into the Scout shops this summer.
you're gonna hear Mark on the podcast at some point
And thanks for getting a touch, mark,
and for helping me set that up.
that's gonna be great fun.
Heard from Jamie Compton,
who's the assistant scout master of Troop 2379,
and Jamie said:
do you have any suggestions on reading material
for first time senior patrol leaders?
We have a relatively young troop,
Jamie. the best thing to do
is to get the senior patrol leader handbook.
How about that?
It's pretty simple.
You can get it over at scoutstufforg.
It's a great resource.
I'll make sure to have a direct link
to it in the podcast notes for you.
Oh, this past week,
oh, I had a post about 10 ways
to frustrate a youth leader,
The 10 things that you, as an adult volunteer, can do
to kind of make being a youth leader difficult
in your troop or your venture crew
or whatever unit you happen to be working with,
And a lot of you got back to me about that.
Ralph Ashbaugh is the assistant scout master
of Troop 457 in Centennial Colorado
And he said the article was so good
I'll have to share it with our adult volunteers
and parents in our parents newsletter.
Can I get your permission to do that?
Yes, of course, Ralph. go right ahead.
Any non-commercial use of anything that I've created
that you wanna share with people
to advance the cause of scouting, go right ahead.
That's a blanket permission to anybody.
If you're using it on a commercial website,
we're gonna need to talk first,
But anything like that, absolutely go right ahead.
That's why I created it.
Heard from Lizzie Kwok, who's a crew advisor.
Thank you for keeping us honest and on track,
and especially me, Lizzie.
The reason I could come up with the 10 things
that we can do to frustrate youth leaders
is I have like a 30-year history
of frustrating youth leaders. so
Paul Clay chimed in and said good thoughts
and worthwhile things to remember.
George Cloud said I just experienced
the anger issue myself last week.
I forgot to count to 10 before I opened my mouth.
Oh man, if I had a nickel for every time I did that,
George, we'd both be rich.
The scout and I apologized to each other
for our behavior and discussed how to avoid it
doing it in the future.
I just need to remember to count to 10 or more
when I feel the frustration setting in.
I also need to get another adult to mediate
when it appears that counting isn't working,
And that's always a good idea, George,
And you know, the thing is is recognizing that
hey, oh, I made a mistake or I'm not quite there yet,
and all of us are not quite there yet.
We're all working on this,
so keep on keeping on, my friend.
A lot of people very quickly spotted,
as soon as I published the article,
that number three of 10 was missing and I fixed it.
I fixed it pretty quick. but thank you.
Everybody gets their red pencil merit badge
for being good proof readers.
Barry Carney checked in to say
words to live by in and out of scouting.
Thanks, Barry,
Patrick Provert. I always remind my junior leaders
that health and safety are where my responsibility
and comfort is theirs.
My two promises were to stop an activity
before somebody got sick or an injured,
or to be the go-between for other adults
should there be complaints or issues.
That's it in a nutshell, Patrick.
Very well put.
James Montigny said I call it blood,
bone and lawsuit. but I agree completely:
Let them learn from their decisions.
Don't let them do something unnecessarily dangerous
and keep other adults out of the way.
And finally, Dana Lenzo checked in and said:
thanks. we all need this reminder sometimes.
Yep, you're right, Dana, especially me.
So I'm glad everybody enjoyed that article.
It's over at scoutmastercgcom
where every week we try and get together
a couple of mornings to have a live chat session.
These are usually Tuesday and Wednesday mornings.
If you keep an eye on our Facebook feed
and our Twitter feed, you'll see an announcement
that we're available at scoutmastercgcom
for a live chat.
A lot of people check in every week.
Dan Stroh, who's a new scout master
from troop 316 in Scottsdale, Arizona,
checked in for the first time this week,
as did many of our frequent flyers,
And we talk about important stuff
and not so important stuff.
So come on over and join us for one of our live chats.
Let's see I got a couple other things here.
Oh, one is: have you seen the t-shirts?
I don't know, I think I mentioned them once before,
but a lot of people have been getting them.
There's one that I did through a Kickstarter campaign
about three or four years ago called Stuff Scouter Saying:
It's like 200 things that you find yourself saying
over and over and over again to your scouts.
Check that one out,
And there's a couple of others too,
And they've been pretty popular.
Kinda surprised me.
Check out the t-shirts
And again I'll have a link where you can see them
in the podcast notes for podcast number 315..
Oh, and I should say about those t-shirts,
It may be me, it's probably me,
But a couple of you know, really honestly,
a couple of people have noted their size. just a little small
Order, maybe a size up, unless you like
a really close fitting t-shirt.
I don't know, it might be a style thing,
I really don't know.
The ones that I got fit me pretty good,
but I did note that they are a little smaller than average.
So word to the wise there.
Hey, if you're a regular reader and listener
and what we're doing is helping you,
you can return the favor in one of two ways.
You can become a backer
And to do that go to scoutmastercgcom,
click the support link at the top of the page.
You'll find a number of different opportunities
where you can help financially support my work
and become a backer.
And this week I wanna take a moment to personally thank
Laura Hoos, Sean Sherwin, Tripp Weikoff,
Kevin Dulce, Robert Lusty and Dan and Rose-
all folks who became backers since last week's podcast.
The other way you can do it is right next to that,
right at the top of the page at scoutmastercgcom,
is a link to Patreon.
Patreon is a way that you can make a subscription payment
of $5 or more per month to keep the podcast
and the blog alive.
So check that out too.
and I wanna make sure to thank Eric Road,
who became a patron this past month.
Well, in this week's podcast
we're gonna go a ways back.
This podcast is back in the 60s,
not the 1960s.
It was podcast 68 or 69..
And I'll be talking to the author
of the Adirondack Mountain Clubs Guide to Outdoor Leadership,
Alex Kosif.
I thought this would be a really great time of year
to replay this particular interview
and remind you about Alex's book,
because if you're planning a high adventure trip
or an extended camping trip this spring or summer,
or really even weekend camping trips,
the information in this book really helps out,
because it deals with a number of concepts
that we don't always get
in the training that scouting offers.
So I'll be talking to Alex about things like
triad of skills that are required
for leading people in the outdoors-
the technical, interpersonal
and judgment skills that are needed.
And we'll also be talking about
something called expedition behavior
and group development and about risk management,
which is everybody's favorite subject, right
Wee-hoo.
Risk management- everybody-
Oh not everybody- likes that,
But all really important things to think about
as you're putting a trip together
and you're gonna go with a group of young people
on an extended trip
And, like I said, even weekend camping trips.
there's a lot of information in this book
that is gonna help you out.
There's both technical information
and there's interpersonal information
and there's judgment information.
So there'll be a link to how to get the book
in the podcast notes, along with Alex's site
and the other links that he mentions during the interview,
And that's gonna do it for this week's podcast.
so let's get started, shall we?
["The Star-Spangled Banner"]?
Today I'm speaking with Alex Kasev,
the founder and director of the Outdoor Safety Institute
in Bozeman, Montana.
We're speaking to Alex from Bozeman,
and he's also the author
of the American Mountain Club's Guide to Outdoor Leadership,
which, if you haven't seen it yet, folks,
it's a great resource.
The real foundation of the book
is in your definition of good outdoor leadership.
What can you tell me about that?
Well, the way I define it is that outdoor leadership
has three kind of foundational components,
And in the book I kind of use the metaphor
of a three-legged stool
and each leg is important for supporting
your overall outdoor leadership ability.
But those legs or foundations are technical skills,
interpersonal skills and judgment skills.
And technical skills are what
that's: your ability to know how to set up tents
and cook food and navigate and all those kind of things.
Interpersonal skills are the ability
to work with other leaders
and with members of your group in a harmonious way.
And then judgment skills:
the ability to see what's going on around you,
both in the environment and in your group
and even with yourself,
and be able to assess what's going on
and make good decisions.
And I certainly focus on safety in the book,
but it's also that judgment also relates
to producing a good outcome,
a good educational experience
or a good overall experience
for the participants in your group as well.
The judgment piece:
you can learn some things about it through reading-
and that it's mostly an experience-based skill,
wouldn't you say
Absolutely?
And that's what I say in the book-
is that this book it's a framework,
it's a starting point,
but the best leaders are the ones
who are getting that hands-on experience
and developing those judgment skills based on experience.
That said, I do think there's room in there
for developing those judgment skills
through really good training programs
And some of the Wilderness First Aid type courses
and leadership courses out there
that try and put you in simulations or scenarios
can really help develop some of those judgment skills.
But at the end of the day,
nothing beats experience working with and leading groups
in the outdoors for building up those judgment skills.
Let's talk about this Wilderness First Responder course.
I was able to take that and I thought it was great.
It was fairly easy.
I did it over a course of two Saturdays a year or so.
How would you encourage somebody to go and take that course?
I think that the two-day Wilderness First Aid course
is just absolutely critical
for anyone who's venturing outside of the reach
of the quick response from the 911 and EMS network.
I've dealt with quite a few backcountry emergencies,
some of them life-threatening,
and it's so important to be able to fall back
to that basic framework about what to think about first.
what are your steps in your process
of dealing with that situation?
I encourage people to take that course.
whenever I can
You go on in the new edition of the book
and elaborate on some techniques
that can be used with teenagers.
The thing that is really important to me
is that the outdoor experience
be something that's different
from teenagers' normal life.
If you go out there and it's kind of a situation
that they experience much like they're at home,
or teachers or parents are always telling them what to do,
it's not gonna be nearly as valuable
as if you give the teenagers
some progressive responsibility
to take on ownership of the activity,
And I think that's something that's really missing
for a lot of youth today,
And so what I'm suggesting is
that progressively turn over responsibility for the trip
so that teens are really both responsible for things
which they aren't always.
So they have to pack their own canoe,
cook their own food,
and if they don't do a good job,
their consequences.
they take over more responsibility
And eventually, by the end of a week-long trip,
they may be doing all the navigation
and you as a leader may be sort of watching
from a distance to make sure
that nothing goes catastrophically wrong,
but giving them a little bit of a leeway
to make some mistakes that aren't gonna be
have any real harm or safety repercussions
And I think that that experience
is something that is really valuable
in terms of building interest in the outdoors,
but also building overall life skills,
decision-making skills for the teenagers
And, ultimately, the activities we're doing in the outdoors.
there's some safety issues,
there's some skill involved,
but they aren't that complicated.
They're a fairly discreet set of skills
and you can train people on those pretty quickly,
especially if they're not-
we're not talking about climbing glaciated mountains,
but the kind of basic activities
we do in the outdoors.
The other thing I think is important
is kind of finding the right balance of challenge and reward,
And I've been with groups
and I've seen other groups out there on the trail
where they just kind of on these huge marches
and that can be rewarding
if everyone's bought into the idea
of accomplishing a lot of miles and getting something done.
but sometimes giving the group a chance
to climb a peak with an amazing view
and having a real feeling of success
that way may be more important
than pushing them really, really hard.
or having the opportunity to have a campfire at night
after a solid day of paddling
is more important than getting in your 30 mile paddle that day.
So there's this fine balance of figuring out
what's the appropriate amount of challenge for a group
and how can the activities that you're doing be rewarding,
either through a sense of accomplishment
or also some kind of other view
or a fun night around the campfire or something like that?
So it's not all about covering miles,
No, I mean I think that some of the groups
that have gotten the most that I've led,
that have gotten the most out of it,
have had their challenging days
and they've had to push a bit,
but they've also had easier days
where there were a lot of fun things:
swimming the lake, fun things to do out there too,
and a chance to bond with teenagers
in a way, other teens in a way
that they don't always get to do at home.
There's a bit of advice that you give
that you may be unaware of that. it's pretty unique,
but I haven't seen it anywhere else
other than in your book
and that, especially when working with teenagers,
is feeding them
And frequent snacks and things like that.
I mean that actually never really occurred to me.
What can you tell me about that?
I think it's brilliant.
Well, it's something that
I mean- I've heard this from other people,
but I've also had this experience-
The group morale and motivation and energy
just sort of precipitously dropping
and all of a sudden kids
who are really excited to be there,
they're not anymore.
It took me a while to put it together,
but often some food will really
really help to solve that situation
and the science behind that is
teenagers have really really high metabolism levels
and they need to eat a lot more frequently
than most adults do
to keep up their blood sugar levels.
and when those blood sugar levels drop,
attitudes really go south.
It has a huge impact on the ability of the group
to work together and get things done.
The key there is that if you're at all hungry,
your group is almost certainly hungrier than you are
and maybe not even be that tuned into that.
but making sure people have the opportunity to say,
hey, I need a snack,
and even encouraging that before people bring it up,
is a great way to keep the group moving.
Just feed and hydrate your group.
It's not just the food. the water helps a lot too.
It's one of the most basic but helpful tips
I've ever come across
And I gotta tell you I know this.
I think I knew this at some level,
but it was never like a part of the plan.
Right,
And that is worth the price of admission on the book alone.
Well, it's just hugely important. and you're right,
All of us who've done any work
with scouts have encountered this in one way or another.
All of a sudden, everybody just kind of hits the wall
and they start dropping like flies
and you're wondering what the heck is going on.
and it's just a granola bar away, really,
Exactly.
Another piece of that, too, is that teenagers,
especially males, have incredibly high appetites.
They can really really eat a lot of food,
and most American boys are used to getting
all the food that they want.
And, of course, if you're backpacking,
you have to carry that food.
But my advice in general is,
especially when you're packing for teenage boys,
is: pack on the heavier side.
You're better off having to carry a little bit more
than to have kids who are complaining about being hungry
and potentially really are hungry
and don't have the food to keep themselves well fueled.
And they don't normally associate hunger
with a drop in morale or a drop in behavior.
They just get cranky,
Exactly.
They're not even aware,
well, I'm hungry. that makes me cranky,
makes me less effective at what I'm doing.
They just go there,
Yep.
So being able to notice that is pretty golden.
One of the things that I really found useful
is your discussion on expedition behavior.
Why is expedition behavior different
from evening meetings that we have and things like that?
What makes it unique?
The idea behind expedition behavior
is that you're really interdependent upon each other
and the group isn't going to function well
if people aren't working together
in someone of a harmonious way.
It really comes out of kind of expeditionary climbing,
like climbing big heat peaks in the Himalayas or in Alaska,
but the concepts are very applicable
to any outdoor kind of experience,
especially multi-day ones. we go on it,
But it sort of begins with the idea of self-awareness,
so being aware of what your own needs are,
And then it flows into the idea
of being able taking responsibility
for taking care of your own needs.
A classic example is somebody goes off to dinner
and leaves their sleeping bag out and it starts to rain
and then their sleeping bag is wet
And that has an impact on the entire group
because they didn't take on their own kind of self-leadership
and taking care of their own things.
And then it moves on from there
to the idea of being kind of supportive of group goals,
So committed to group goals, tolerant of each other.
You know people on- I mean, I'm sure you've had this experience.
people come into these things
with different comfort levels for being in the outdoors
and different physical ability levels
And it's often easy for those who are more comfortable
or physically able to be let's see like critical
or not supportive of those who are less comfortable.
But if people are supportive within the group
and committed to the group goals,
that support can really really help those people
who are struggling through,
can make them feel more a part of the group
and it can help them to really overcome
some of those challenges and make the experience a success.
And another piece of that whole expedition behavior
is good communication and being able
to express yourself in a supportive, non-critical way
with other members of the group.
So this is the expedition behavior concept,
is something that leaders really need to have in themselves,
but it's something that the whole group can really commit to.
And one of the things that I like to do
with groups of teenagers particularly
is introduce this kind of concept of expedition behavior-
or you can call it something else if you want.
So you're going to have a group early on
and have the group help to define
what the expectations of each other are
And you might have to prompt them a little.
Do you say, do you want people to be supportive
when you're having a hard time
or do you want them to be critical?
And they're inevitably,
especially within the scouting community,
they're going to understand the value of being supportive
And that early commitment from the group
to those concepts can be really helpful later on,
kind of say: hey remember, early in the trip
we talked about expedition behavior
and being supportive of one another
when we're having a hard time,
And for a lot of teens that'll really click
and they say: oh yeah, Joe's having a hard time,
Now's not the time to complain about him slowing us down,
Now's the time to maybe take a little weight from him
and joke with him a little and try and cheer him up.
You hit on something else that I think
in their limited awareness,
teenagers don't always realize:
if they're uncomfortable
or if they're physically incapable of doing something,
they get kind of afraid and they get very reluctant
and they get really recalcitrant-
I think that's the word I'm looking for-
about moving ahead or trying to do anything.
And I don't think that they associate-
just like they don't associate- being cranky
or difficult with not having enough to eat or drink.
They don't associate the fact that they're kind of afraid
or uncomfortable with something
with the way that they behave.
Understanding that and kind of inculcating in the group
these expedition behaviors that you're talking about,
you're gonna avoid an awful lot of that,
Absolutely. I mean, that's so critically important
is I really believe in outdoor experiences
and a kind of concept of challenge by choice,
So that you shouldn't be out there forcing people
to do something that they don't wanna do,
Although there might be situations
where you have to get through a bunch of miles
because you have to finish the trip.
But for the most part,
if that group can be supportive of one another,
you really avoid those situations
where you call that recalcitrant,
where teens get really reluctant to do stuff
And often you're right, they cannot verbalize
I'm scared, I'm tired, I'm hungry.
But if the group's really supporting each other
and the teens- the boys are having an easier time,
are really supportive and encouraging
and helpful to those who are having a harder time,
the net accomplishments the group can achieve
are so, so, so much higher
than if you let the people who are having a hard time
drag at the back of the pack
and feel miserable for themselves.
It's really, really crucial to understand these dynamics
and then to put them to work.
So let's spend a little time just going over
some of the techniques that you have in the book
as far as leaders and group development goes.
In encouraging group development,
it's helpful to understand that there's
kind of a natural group development process
that most groups go through
when they're on an outdoor experience,
And there's some variation,
but the basic stages are forming,
storming, norming, performing,
and then there's kind of one called adjourning.
So basically what happens is
when people first come together for an experience,
they're kind of excited to be there.
They're trying to get a sense of what it's all about,
who the other people are.
But then, as challenges set in
and as they have to cook together
and sleep in tents together
and hike long miles together,
they get into a storming stage
where there's some conflict
amongst group members potentially.
And that's actually not bad.
It's okay to have some of that conflict
because it helps to establish
how the group's gonna work together.
But if you can help facilitate that
by setting some of those
expedition behavior expectations early,
that's helpful.
Then you move into kind of a norming phase,
which is figuring out how we work together. well,
Leaving the fighting, the storming,
the argument behind but working better together.
And then from that norming
you get into a performing stage
where the group can really really work well together.
And not every group gets there.
It depends on the leadership,
the activity you're doing,
the length of the program, the participants.
and then the adjourning phase
is kind of the hey, we're leaving
and people starting to realize
that this isn't gonna go on forever
and that people are gonna go and sort of separate
at the end of the trip
And at each stage of this.
there's no science to this,
It's really more of an art.
but it's being able to kind of
to step back as a leader
and not impose your own perspective, as much
as try and look at the group
and how people are interacting
and even how they physically look.
Are they kind of lazily,
literally dipping their paddle in the canoe?
Are they did they have their head down
and they're looking miserable
backpacking?
Are they kind of determined looking?
And those little observations
about individuals and groups
can really help you understand
who needs support,
how you might be able to encourage certain people,
how you who in the group's doing really well
and you might be able to you task them
with helping other group members
who are struggling a little more.
So that assessment thing-
there's no rule book for it,
but it's being able to kind of
leave behind your own perspective,
your own perhaps tired state,
struggling, hiking or your own viewpoint
and really look objectively at what's going on in the group
and try and help the group
move through some of their challenges
and work together to achieve a greater good.
Scouters will be pretty familiar-
well, at least ones who have been through
some of the more advanced training
like wood badge and things
would be- are gonna be real familiar
with the storming, norming and forming
and the forming, norming, storming
or the inks and those dynamics.
but just being cognizant of these processes
is such an incredibly important thing.
When you're working in that
kind of group development phase
and you're getting through that,
you're also minimizing a lot of the,
a lot of possible difficulties
you're gonna run into.
I wanna I wanna spend some time
talking about a very important part of the book
which is risk management.
Here's what I think, Alex.
I think a lot of us run into it
in our professional lives
and there's somebody who is like the risk manager
and nobody really wants to see that guy
come through their office door.
but I'm a big advocate of understanding,
especially in these kind of outdoor adventures,
the role of risk management,
and I know that you spend a lot of time
assessing this stuff.
So give me a starter course
in a couple of minutes here.
What if? if I'm headed off
to take a group canoeing for a week
or backpacking for a week,
what is it that I need to be thinking about?
that I might not know?
Here's summary: there is that a lot of people
or don't really wanna deal with. the risk manager
is very accurate, and this is primarily
what I do for a living actually
is help. outdoor programs deal with safety
and, to some degree, liability issues,
And one of the things that's really important to me,
before like delving into the course idea,
is that as a culture we're very risk averse,
We don't like danger,
and I think it's really important-
and I think that the scouts actually really help
to encourage this in our society a little-
to understand that life
and also rewarding growth experiences have risks
and we can't eliminate all of those risks.
But at the other side of it is my advocacy for risk
doesn't mean that it's an excuse
for not conducting the activities in the outdoors
that we do in a responsible way.
So there's a lot we can do
to make the activities we're doing a little bit safer.
But at the end of the day, there is always gonna be risk
and every trip that goes out
should have some level of a risk management plan.
What are the likely hazards
that are gonna be encountered in? really, three areas.
One, the particular environment we're in.
is there gonna be a big river crossing
we're gonna have to do
and potentially could the water be high
on that river crossing?
and then the activity we're doing is,
if it's backpacking, is one of the hazards
maybe lightning up on a peak or a ridge,
or is it swimming in a remote cold pond lake?
and then hazards within the group-
and that's a really important one-
is looking at your who's going
and thinking about the physical,
emotional, health needs of the participants in that group
and are there special steps you need to take for those
Everything you identify as a risk?
there's a little process of kind of figuring out:
can we, is there a way we can reduce the risk?
Can we eliminate it potentially
if it's not important to the activity,
or can we just say that that's an inherent risk
that we need to accept as part of this.
So looking at those things
and thinking about how can you modify them
without taking all the fun out of it.
there's the looking at things in advance
and how are you gonna deal with them,
knowing how to respond if something does go wrong.
This just isn't because there is a fear of being sued
or some kind of liability problem or something like that.
this is for real and this is how you know
you can kill people if you don't do this.
Is it kind of?
And that's a tricky balancing act.
People often view this safety stuff
as being driven by the liability thing,
but I work with some of the best lawyers
who specialize, actually, in defending organizations
from lawsuits and they all, front and center, tell you
that don't bother with any of this stuff-
the safety stuff in risk management-
if all you're concerned about is being sued.
you do it because you care about the people
you're taking into the outdoors
and that you wanna provide these experiences,
but you also wanna do it in a conscientious manner.
It takes a bit of an ego to be a scout leader
and there's a lot of bravado involved
and things like that,
and I think it's particularly valuable
having someone like yourself
who has a little perspective on this
and who actually studies these things,
to back up the idea that this is really important.
There are some hazards out there.
it's not disproportionate.
I mean, if you look at some statistical information,
other activities these teens could be doing
are much more hazardous,
including a lot of common high school sports
are much more hazardous than the type
of outdoor activities we're talking about.
but at the end of the day,
what do you think the most dangerous part
of backpacking or canoeing trip did?
Oh well, I know the answer.
that's getting in the car and driving there.
Absolutely, make sure people are doing basic stuff
like wearing seat belts, driving the speed limit,
not driving when you're exhausted. after
at the end of a long day,
perhaps hiking out to the trailhead,
so that's where you can really have an impact too.
These are things that you have to keep
in the forefront of your mind
when you're leading this kind of thing.
and it's just incredibly important.
Here we are, we're captain and Mr Buzzkill.
now we're just
Yeah, I know,
and it's really tempting.
I know how tempting it is to get out there
and you're having a good time.
you don't want to deal with this stuff,
but at the end of the day,
if it becomes kind of a systematic approach
and it's just how you, as a leader, do things
and it's how your scouts, as a leader, do things,
or is how your scouts in the group
are used to doing things.
it's less of a buzzkill.
I think it's really actually liberating
because if you're sure,
or at least reasonably sure,
of your skills
and you're reasonably sure of
you've taken the time
and sat down and sketched out a risk management plan
and you've done your best to assess
all of the different things that you're going to do
and what considerations you're going to need to have
and where you can bug out if you need to get out,
it's pretty liberating
because you don't have to make that up on the spot.
Well, I really appreciate you having taken the time
to talk with us
and I've got to say
the book. it's an excellent resource.
it will definitely give you a big leg up
in learning how to be a really effective,
intelligent outdoor leader.
So, Alex, thanks again for taking the time to talk to us.
Thanks, Clark, I really appreciate. it's fun to talk
to you, fun conversation,
and people can also feel free to contact me.
they can head over to our website
at OutdoorSafetyInstitutecom
and you can contact me off of that website
or look at what we've got available on the website there.
Well, thanks very much, bye-bye,
Bye.
Hey, thank you so much for listening
to this 315th edition of the Scoutmaster Podcast.
It's easy to keep in touch.
just go over to scoutmastercgcom.
There's 1,600 plus articles there on the blog,
all about scouting in the outdoors,
and you can also sign up to receive updates
to the blog by email.
You can join us in the vast panorama of social media.
There are over 13,000 people who follow us on Facebook,
1,500 people who tweet along with us on Twitter,
a bunch of people who peruse
the pultritudinous pictures
we brought for the Pinterest.
You can watch us at YouTube and all that yada, yada, yada, yada.
but you say to me, you say
I do not put the you in YouTube,
I have no interest in Pinterest,
I can't face Facebook.
Twitter just kind of makes me better.
Well, that's okay, monkey,
Just sail into the late 1990s
and fire off a good old fashioned email.
You can reach me ClarkGreen at Clark
at scoutmastercgcom,
C-L-A-R-K-E
at scoutmastercgcom.
Now, none of those methods
of keeping in touch work for you.
Here's what you do:
Get your signal mirror
and a very strong flashlight.
I recommend at least 1,000 lumens or more.
Train the flashlight on the mirror,
Direct the mirror's reflection towards the dog star. serious,
And I'll be sure to get in touch
to answer all of your questions.
Well, listen now. it should be abundantly clear
that the Scoutmaster blog
and the Scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications of,
nor are they sponsored by or sanctioned
by any scouting organization whatsoever.
No, it is just me.
I have discovered that I can talk into a microphone
and then put that on the web
and call it a podcast.
How about that?
And it's just my way of trying to help my fellow Scouters
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
And speaking of fun,
here he is our founder, Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Why? thank you, sir.
Until next time, everyone.